hi 3/8 I am going to show you some of my
favorite recipes during springtime in
Japan March 3rd it's God's day in Japan
called Hina Matsuri across the country
families put up dots that represent our
traditional royal wedding ceremony from
the Heian period however because of
space and budget model families tend to
only decorate the top level which it's
the Emperor or deities AMA and the
Empress ohina sama we celebrate in a
Matsuri by eating - sushi sushi sushi
means scattered sushi commonly we use
the sushi rice as a base and top it with
thinly sliced Amla lotus root or cooked
shrimp for this video we made rolled
sushi and decorated with popular juices
toppings it's easy to eat with fingers
so it's a perfect finger food for
parties
[Music]
Oh hanami is a really fun picnic custom
that happens during cherry blossom
season it's a little difficult to
translate but a hanami essentially means
taking a moment to enjoy flowers for
Japanese people it's typically
associated with cherry blossom viewing
during April we picnic with bento boxes
and onigiri and admire how beautiful the
cherry blossoms are it's also beautiful
in the evening when the Sun is setting
when it's dark
a lot of the mountains and treats light
up to end a perfect day of hanami unlike
in America you can bring alcohol with
you so often family friends or coworkers
get together for happy hour under the
cherry blossoms
another great hanami dish is called
takikomi gohan takikomi gohan is an OG
one pot recipe that enhances the rice
with seasoning and seasonal vegetables
this dish is a crowd-pleaser when a
hanami picnic during the springtime
takenoko or bamboo shoot is a popular
ingredient used in many dishes I like to
make onigiri with maitake Kimiko Han
it's flavorful and a nostalgic
[Music]
we enjoy watching cherry blossoms during
the spring but did you know we eat them
as well during springtime we use soft
cured cherry blossoms for both desserts
and savory food not only can you eat it
but it looks beautiful so you can also
eat with your eyes it's very salty so
make sure to rinse it first after you
wash it you can use it on a lot of
different things like these cheesecakes
[Music]
salt cure the cherry blossoms are not
really sweet and it doesn't drastically
change the flavor of your dish so it's
an easy way to add a little style and
give me that springtime feeling
[Music]
Kagari maki is a decorative type of
sushi roll for this video we made the
pattern looks like a flower after making
a long roll
you cut it to reveal an intricate
cross-section Kesari Maki is also unique
because it uses different type of seeds
in the rice to achieve the pink color we
use the clergyman taiko which is spicy
fish egg a popular ingredients in Japan
you can also use salmon as a substitute
it's a great way to show of sushi
parties and hanami picnics this is sushi
roll technique it's similar to candy
making technique called Quinta ramen we
went to Japan and filmed how to make
Quintero ma for a while stir episode I'm
not sure you can make king ptolemee home
but you can definitely make kadar emoji
this technique is getting popular and
people often experiment with a lot of
different patterns such as anime
characters or seasonal patterns like
Halloween and Christmas themes
this type of sushi is advanced but if
you are looking for something fun to do
with your friends and family it can be a
fun weekend project once you understand
the logic behind the designs any
patterns you want even more advanced
than this one
[Music]
finally this is a desert called Ichigo
daifuku springtime it's strawberry time
and this is one of my favorite seasonal
Japanese dessert at the center is a
strawberry which it's then wrapped in
sweet bean paste called uncle or encased
in soft mochi I use the microwave to
make the mochi for this video but you
can use a stopped-up as well just be
careful the mochi it's extremely hot and
very sticky right out of the microwave
use a lot of cornstarch or potato starch
to make sure the mochi doesn't stick to
your hands the sweet bean strikes a nice
balance
with the tar strawberry so it's a desire
of subtle and delicious contrasts
springtime is my favorite time of the
air because of visually pleasing food
and going for picnic with friends I hope
you can be the Japan during the
springtime and try some of the recipe I
recommended today oh yes
[Music]
[Music]